de l'engagement les meilleurs athlètes
de sept clubs franciliens sur la piste
les finales de la coupe d'hiver ont tenu
toutes leurs promesses ce dimanche 11
février au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines
pour cette deuxième édition 110 sportifs
ont été sélectionnés sur quatre épreuves
pour participer au rendez vous sur les
quatre manches
nous avons eu 650 participants
donc la deuxième édition a été une
réussite ça monte en puissance
tous les coureurs manifestent beaucoup
d'intérêt à venir à saint quentin
au programme des épreuves d'omnium et de
vitesse de la catégorie minimes à
seniors objectif de cette journée
proposé aux coureurs un entraînement
grandeur nature pour les faire
progresser
le fait d'avoir à faire des épreuves
c'est vrai que l'on gagne en expérience
puisque on est bien encadré dans le club
il ya de bons conseils donc c'est
surtout tactiquement qu'avec j'ai bien
progressé
la dernière compétition j'ai fait tomber
du coup là sur cette compétition la c2a
me rassurer en compétition donc plus
puisse me coller aux autres sans avoir
peur
le rendez vous a également pour objectif
de faire découvrir la piste olympique du
vélotour nationale et ses virages de
huit mètres au coureur les images sont
assez impressionnants au début parce que
c'est vraiment foutu
après
les lignes droites c'est moins
impressionnant mais il ya beaucoup de
sensations quand on plonge dans les
virages
c'est une super piste faut vous c'est là
l'un des plus beaux vélodrome au monde
donc on a vraiment la chance de faire
nora nos compétitions sur une telle
piste pareil une troisième édition
devrait être programmée l'année
prochaine elle pourrait cette fois-ci
inclure des coureurs venus de toute
l'europe
[Musique]